CHLOE COMBI: Thank you
very much for having me.
Yes, my name is
Chloe Combi, and I'm
here today to talk
to you about my book,
"Generation Z, Their
Voices, Their Lives."
And to reiterate, it
was a strange kind
of genesis, this book, because
I'm not originally a writer.
I was a school teacher.
And I was a schoolteacher
straight out of university,
and I taught in
quite challenging
inner London schools.
And there, I started my
own education charity
called Write Club, which got
quite a lot of media attention.
And because of that, i started
writing for newspapers,
sort of darkly humorous pieces
about the realities of teaching
life.
And then from there, I
started writing features
about, I guess, the grittier
aspects of teen life,
so on grooming, and
busing, and gangland
culture, and dog fighting.
And yes, those did get
quite a lot of attention.
I think they were
well timed as well.
And what became very
clear was that there
was this real need for this
window into teenage life.
So Generation Z was born.
And the concept, I
suppose, was simple enough.
it was gonna take about 3
years to research and write it,
and I'd already kind of started.
And the aim was to interview
2,000 teenagers, which I hit.
So it's a big
sample of teenagers.
And this isn't a book just
about gritty teenagers.
It's from the most kind of
normal teenage experience
to the most extreme, because
you have to get the whole range.
And so I think
it's a good insight
into who teenagers in the
UK in the 21st century are.
So who are Generation Z?
Well, we're already
talked a bit about this.
And actually,
originally, and I wanted
to call this book
Generation I. I
didn't want to call
it Generation Z,
but we'll go back
into that later.
And the small i,
because I thought
the I for the
narcissistic I, which
is a quality that this
generation are accused
of a lot, the i,
which obviously is
a sort of sly nod to Apple,
which most teenagers are
completely enthralled
with, I'm sure you know.
And obviously, i
for information,
which is a real quality
of everyday life
that we're all into.
But there was a fear
that people would
assume that it was a
book about technology,
and it's not at all, because
I'm not a tech expert.
So many things.
So it became Generation Z.
And actually Generation
Z was more of
understood as a sociological
label than I realized.
Because we've all
heard of Generation X.
That was a real thing, and
there was books on Generation X.
But Generation Y, which I'm
guessing most people in here
fall into, kind of fell
through the cracks?
And they were sometimes called
the millennial generation,
and sometimes called the
post-baby boomer generation.
So on a very simple
level, Generation Z
are the children of
Generations Y and Generation X.
And some of them
probably actually
have grandparents now who
are Generation X, which
is a bit terrifying.
And for me, for my purposes,
they were teenagers.
Everyone who I
interviewed in this book
and who is in this book is
between the ages of 13 to 19.
But for some people
writing about Generation Z,
they widen that
cohort a little bit,
and they're probably
more 12 to 22 year-olds.
And currently there's a lot
of scare pieces about how
the oldest of Generation Z are
about to enter the workplace,
and ill-equipped they are, and
how they can't talk properly,
and don't write properly,
and they write in text speak,
and speak in text speak.
But for my purposes,
they were teenagers.
On a much more complex
level, they were as complex
as any big group of people.
They're as complicated, and as
strange, and as multifaceted,
and as normal, and as
likable, and a unlikable,
and as difficult to define
as any other large group.
But there were themes, and
they were coming up again,
and again, and again.
They became quite
predictable, and they
formed the natural
chapters of the book.
And not in any order,
and I can't never
remember all of these, but
they are sex, of course,
and body, of course,
school, family, friendships
and relationships, crime,
gender, class, race,
the future, and technology.
And technology particularly
I wanted to focus on a bit,
obviously, considering
this audience.
But also because
it is interesting
for this generation, because
this is the first generation--
this is the thing that
differentiates this generation.
This is the first generation
that have grown up
with the internet.
They've grown up
with social media.
with mobile phones,
and they've never known a
world without those things.
The rest of it's probably
can remember a world when
we didn't have those things,
but this generation has never
known world without
them, and it's massively
influenced who they are,
and how they've evolved,
and how they think.
And on the way, I
actually met a few kids,
several who spring
to mind, and I'm
gonna read you a
very short piece, who
didn't realize that the
internet used to not exist.
And they actually thought
I was pulling their leg,
and they had to go and google
this fact, which obviously
in ironic in and of itself.
And I'm going to read you a
very short piece from the book.
Now this is a trigger warning.
There's swearing.
And if you do end up
reading this book,
there's lots of
swearing, and there's
lots of quite grim stuff in it.
There's lots of really funny
and happy stuff as well,
but there is swearing.
And I'm not going to give
you the whole description,
but these are three
boys, and basically
them describing their
relationship every day
with technology.
And these three boys
have never read a book,
except "Holes" by Louis Sachar,
because they were made to,
and "Romeo and
Juliette," because they
were made to at school.
And they figured
that they probably
accrued individually,
probably about $250 a week
online in some way,
like gaming and so on.
And these are three
different boys.
One's called Raj, one's called
Abdi, and one's called Jouad,
Do you know what I
found out the other day?
That the internet
used to not exist.
I didn't know that, and my
mind was all like, the fuck.
And this is the next one.
You're such a fool.
Of course it didn't
used to exist.
Mobile phones used to not exist.
That's jokes, man.
Can you imagine
no mobile phones?
How would you even
talk to people?
With your mouth, you dickhead.
But no, man.
The world would be so shit
without all the stuff we have.
The teachers are all
negative about it
and say it's sucking our
brains up, but that's bullshit.
I was gaming with this sick
guy in Columbia the other day.
He told me the
shit about Colombia
that I didn't know
from geography lessons.
That's educational.
And he told me he gangbanged
my mum and sisters as well.
But that's just
gaming, isn't it?
You cuss each other to the max.
It's psychological
banter, isn't it?
You want them to get all pissed
off with you so that they lose.
And it goes on.
So that leads on to my
next question, which
is do teenage boys and girls
engage with and get treated
by the internet differently?
well, that piece obviously
referenced gaming quite a lot.
And I'm not gonna go into gaming
today, because I don't game,
and I don't really know
enough about the logistics
and the politics of it to
really go into in detail.
What I do know is that
it's a real red button
topic at the
moment, particularly
to do with gender,
because there's
this whole thing about how it's
a traditionally male thing,
and more and more
girls want to game.
But thumbs up to teenage boys.
I will say that I met
very few who seemed
to have a problem with that.
They were very inclusive
about the idea.
And that seems to
be more of an issue
that a few gray men seem
to have a problem with,
and I'll let you make
of that what you will.
Both genders are, as
I'm sure you know,
hugely, hugely, hugely
in social media.
But that relationship's
evolving and changing really,
really quickly.
And I guess what
you would describe
as the granddaddy of social
media, which would be Facebook,
is in its death
throes with teenagers.
They're completely out.
They leaving by the hundreds
of thousands every day.
And for the reason,
and I quote, it's
because there's too many
old people on there.
Their parents and their
grandparents are now on there,
and 16 year-olds don't want
to hang out with their parents
and grandparents in real
life, and they certainly
don't online.
I don't think teenagers
ever really embraced
Twitter that much.
I think it's much more of
a middle class adult thing.
I think that middle class
adults love to go on Twitter
and either show off or
get offended by things.
I think that kids like
Twitter for stalking people,
but other than that,
they don't really
talk about in any kind
of passionate way.
The three things that
they're really into,
the mainstream stuff, there's
lots of underground stuff,
but the three big ones
they're into at the moment
are Snapchat,
Instagram, and YouTube.
Now YouTube I'm not
gonna talk about too
much, because it almost
deserves a talk unto itself.
Because the YouTubers are
the teen-appointed new rock
stars and royalty.
They are huge, and these are
completely teen-led trends.
Like, beyond the ages of
19, probably PewDiePie
means absolutely
nothing to you, but they
are like these little gods
to millions and millions
of teenagers.
And what's interesting is this
is not industry or adult-led.
This is entirely
teen-led, which goes
to show that they have quite
a lot of autonomy and power
on the internet.
But the one I wanted
to talk about today
was actually Instagram,
because there I
think there is a really
interesting gender
political paradigm
that comes up.
Male vanity is a thing,
and it's a growing thing,
and there's lots of issues
about boys and their body image.
But if you look at
the Instagram page
of the average teenage
boy, it revolves
around stuff or action.
Stuff being cool, if
they're a bit older,
cool cars, cool headphones,
cool shades, school threads.
And or it revolves
around action,
so like, on holiday
surfing with their mates,
or on the side of a
mountain with their hands
in the air at sunset.
Or if they're a
bit younger, maybe
like looning around a
classroom with their friends,
and making those kinds of signs.
Girls Instagram page
revolve around the self.
And by the self, I mean the
selfie self-- very stylized,
very sexualized, the duck face.
Now it's the fish face,
which duck face is very 2015
and we're nearly 2016.
Lots and lots of pouting,
and lots of focus on body,
in a very kind of
sexualized way.
And when I was writing the
book, the girls, lots of girls,
told me about selfie parties.
And selfie parties,
ostensibly, I guess,
are like slumber parties.
Butt the whole idea is
you get together, sit
around each other's houses,
and rather than watch
a movie or talk about boys,
you doll each other up,
take hundreds or
thousands of selfies,
manipulate them, face
tune them, although you
don't admit to that, and
then put them on Instagram.
And there's a
competitive element
as to who gets the most
likes or the most comments.
And obviously, the holy grail of
those comments come from boys.
And I think that that's
pushing both genders
into roles I think a lot of them
are really uncomfortable with.
Girls become the
exhibitionists on trial,
and boys become the
voyeurs and the judges.
And lots of them have said
to me, I don't like this.
And what a shame in 2015,
where most adults, probably
with the exception
of like Donald Trump,
have decided that beauty
pageants are really naff,
that teenagers are in this
endless online beauty pageant.
And you can say, yeah, yeah,
yeah, they don't have to do it.
But I think the teenagers,
social media, and Instagram,
is kind of like the tree
falling in the woods.
If they're not on it, they
feel like they don't exist.
And what really
interested me was
one of the undisputed queens
of Instagram, Kylie Jenner, who
millions of them follow,
and unless you've
lived under a rock, a happy
rock, for the last five years,
you know that Kylie
Jenner is the half-sister
of Kim Kardashian, who
originally became famous,
ostensibly, because her mum put
her sex tape on the internet.
Her mum did that.
And I Kylie Jenner has sort
of become the next generation.
And it was her 18th
a few weeks ago.
And there was wall-to-wall,
endless, global, breathless
coverage of this--
what she wore,
what her mouth
looked like, what was
on her feet, what was around her
neck, what her boyfriend looked
like.
I mean, every possible thing.
On the very same day, a
very different 18-year-old,
Nobel Peace Prize
winner, Taliban-botherer,
and pretty awesome
person, Malala Yousafzai,
opened a school for girls
who hadn't been receiving
an education, and that
received minimal coverage,
particularly in comparisons to
Kylie Jenner's 18th birthday.
So you can see why teenage
girls and teenage boys
are assimilating this
message that it's not
how brave you are, or
how clever you are,
or how innovative you
are, all those things.
It's basically if you've
got hot tits and ass.
And that's what we're reducing
girls to via Instagram.
Which leads me to
my next question.
I hope.
Is technology and social
media turning all teenage
into bullies and victims?
Well, that's really
a question, and 2014,
35% of all 11 to
17 year-olds had
said that they'd
been cyberbullied,
and I think that's growing.
That's doubled on
last year, so I'd
be interested to see the
figures for this year and next.
Now, I guess that's a question
we could ask of all ourselves.
And I know you probably
know better than anyone
that the big criticism
of the internet
is how lawless and
unregulated it is,
and how people do
things that they
wouldn't do in ordinary life.
And this absolutely
applies to teenagers.
The hot crucible that
the internet already is,
when you add
teenagers to that mix,
it becomes a nuclear
reactor, because teenagers
are very vulnerable,
but they're also
liable to do very stupid things.
If you go into any school
in any part of the country,
no matter how good
the school is,
and you say the
word cyberbullying
to the head teacher
or teacher, they
will make hair tearing motions.
Cyberbullying is an
enormous problem.
In fact, it probably is the
biggest past all our problem
currently in schools.
And the reason is very
simple, that bullying has been
an age old problem in schools.
Hands up if you were
ever bullied at school.
OK, what cyberbullying has
done is taken bullying out
of the classroom, out
of the playground,
out of the bus stop, and it has
placed it in a 24 hour a day,
seven days a week, 365
days a year, potential.
Kids can be bullied
at 2:00 in the morning
from their bedrooms.
Kids can be bullied
whilst they're
on summer holiday
with their parents.
And kids are really creative,
and they're really mean.
I've seen fake Twitter
pages being set up.
I've seen Facebook hate
groups being set up.
I've seen them hack into
each of these emails,
and put them online for
other people to see.
And that's with my own eyes.
And if you wanted to ask
what the wicked stepmother
of this kind of cyberbullying
is, particularly
from the head teachers point of
view, it would be and sexting.
Does anyone know
what sexting is?
OK, just in case
you don't, sexting
is a sexually explicit text with
a nude or semi-nude photograph.
Now, as you can imagine, these
are wildly popular with kids.
If you get a group
of kids in a room,
probably from the
age of 15 plus,
I'd say probably 75% of them
have either sent a sext,
received a sext or
been privy to a sext.
And this is a really,
really, really huge problem,
because at any one
time in a school,
you've potentially got
live with the ability
to go viral pictures of
underage kids floating around.
And I've seen and heard of
actual-- if you think about it,
the ethics behind it, if a
14 year-old sends another 14
year-old a nude
picture of themselves,
theoretically, they're in
possession of child porn.
And the schools every week
are having to bring police in,
and there's been arrests,
and in all sorts, things
that won't make the
press, because obviously
it's the kind of
thing that they're not
going to be particularly
transparent about.
I think this leads
to the next thing.
This sexting thing
is being fueled
hugely by another red button
of the internet, which is,
is the internet
turning all teenagers
into wannabe porn stars,
pornographers, and sex mad?
Well, I would say to
this, no, no, and no.
And the reason being is
because teenagers, not
this generation,
but all teenagers,
are already fairly sex mad.
A lot of porn watching, which
is being done in huge amounts,
a lot of porn watching
is because kids can.
It's because it's there.
And I don't believe that any
teenager who found, say, a porn
mag in a bush in the '70s, '80s,
or '90s was like, nah, dude.
I'm gonna wait till
2015 to look at this.
To be a teenager
is to be curious
about sex and pornography.
But does that mean that I don't
think that porn is a problem?
No, I don't.
And here's why.
If teenagers were watching
the kind of porn films
that maybe they
made in the '70s,
with big bushes
and big moustaches,
like refrigerator operators,
that would be one thing.
But they're not.
A huge commission
study into pornography
that was made recently
revealed that 80%,
and I'd say that's probably
modest, 80% of pornography
now contains some extent of
violence and sexual violence.
So kids are watching porn
films with depicted rape,
depicted gang-rape, S&M,
beatings, slapping around,
and all manner of sex acts.
And I've done a lot
of writing on this,
so I've had to do my research.
And of course that is impacting
on how they see each other
and how they see sex.
And I'm gonna go
out on a limb here
and say yes, there are
some teenage girls who
watch pornography, but
the vast, vast majority
of teenage consumption
of pornography
has been done by boys.
And I promise you they are
somewhere between watching it
quite regularly to
mainlining the stuff.
And it's having an impact.
It's manifesting
behaviorally, certainly.
In this country, we have
a problem with consent,
and not just with teenagers,
but particularly with teenagers.
There is confusion
over what no means,
when people can say no,
what date rape means,
what rape means.
And I do believe that
is being slightly led
by porn, because in porn,
there is no such thing as no,
and there's very,
very few boundaries.
And another very quick reading
that I wanted to do for you
today, which was from a boy who
I spoke to, I spoke to a lot
over the last couple
of years, who's
actually being
treated for I guess
you could say a porn addiction.
I remember the first
time I saw porn.
I was probably about six.
I went to a primary school that
was attached to a high school,
and there was always old
kids most giving us shit.
But some were OK.
This bunch of lads were
like, look at this.
Look at this.
And it was a porn film.
I don't know what
it was exactly,
by I remember being
really interested in it,
and knowing it was probably
bad, but in a good way.
I'd say I was about nine, and
a lot of the boys at school
were either interested
in seeing porn,
or had been watching it a bit.
You'd have to be pretty
clueless not to be aware of it.
I didn't get a
mobile phone until I
was 11, when the obsession
really started, because it
was so easy to access.
But I'd definitely
seen a lot before then.
A lot of my mates
have mobile phones,
and after football,
we'd sometimes
watch a bit on
John's phone, who had
this wicked phone with a
really good screen even then.
We'd all cuss each other,
saying you've got an erection,
you pervert.
And we would deny
it, but it's porn.
What else is gonna happen?
So he was kind of exposed
to porn at the age of nine.
And I don't think
that's unusual at all.
In fact, I know it's not,
because I've done a lot of work
in primary schools.
So a bit bleak,
but before I move
on to the last couple of
things, sex talk is rather 1997.
I think in education we
need to perhaps bring
in a porn talk,
and porn education,
and about how it doesn't
replicate real life.
But with things like
cyberbullying, and sexting,
and what happens, potentially,
if you put a picture up online,
I think that maybe companies
like this, and educators,
and politicians, perhaps need
to get together and really
clarify the dangers and the
pitfalls of the internet,
and put them there for
everyone to see every time you
go online, because
I think lots of kids
are really, really
running into trouble.
I know lots of kids are
really running into trouble,
because they do things on the
internet without thinking,
without realizing.
So not a completely
different topic,
but a slightly different
topic, because I know Rob
was really curious
about this one.
This is a country with
a class obsession,
and it's a country
with a class problem.
There are far too many kids who
are falling through the cracks,
and neglected.
And I think with this particular
government, that's increasing.
But that can almost have
a technological slant
which I think almost
pertains to you guys.
If you think about a middle
class kid, or a middle class
and upwards, a kid who's
reasonably privileged and well
looked after, they're gonna have
lots of access to technology.
They almost always
have a smartphone.
They might well have a
laptop or a personal computer
in their bedroom.
They might have
a tablet that was
given to them by the school, or
given to them by their parents.
And they'll do things, all the
things that we just discussed.
They'll watch films.
They'll watch movies.
They'll upload photographs,
or chat to their friends,
and they'll do schoolwork.
Kids who come from much
less privileged backgrounds,
I'd say if anything that
their access to technology
and how they use it is
more important to them.
Kids who don't have
families and don't
have parents who keep
tabs and look after them,
they form alternative
family structures that
revolve around their peers.
And technology, and particularly
mobile phone technology
is an absolutely essential
and intrinsic part of that.
It's how, basically, they
look after each other.
There is an endless
where are you?
What you doing?
Are you safe?
Are the feds about?
Are there enemy foe around?
And so on.
And doing this book,
writing this book,
I spent a lot of time with
kids, what's called on road.
And I never used street parlance
because I sound idiotic,
but on road, basically,
is street parlance
for on the road.
And people assume that that
means a child or a teenager
is in a gang that's affiliated
to criminal activity.
And actually, it can mean that,
but it doesn't necessarily.
It often just means that
a kid is on the road,
because the road is
more safe than the home
that they come from.
And that can be mostly for
really upsetting reasons.
Bad step-parents, bad parents,
drug abuse, prostitution,
getting knocked around, or
just getting kicked out.
So there's countless
kids on road,
whether they're full
time or part time.
But to go back to the
more organized gangs,
there's much, much,
much scaremongering
about whether they're utilizing
technology to organize crime,
and utilizing technology
to threaten each other,
and using technology to recruit.
And the answer to
that is, hell yes.
Absolutely they are.
They're using technology
very, very, very cleverly,
and very smartly.
And it's very, very
simple as to why.
20 years ago, anyone on the
street affiliated to crime
had to rely on what was
going on and to understand
what was going on
through word of mouth,
through face-to-face
confrontation,
through graffiti, through
the colors that they wore.
But now particularly with
mobile phones and social media,
this internalized
endless newspaper
as to street news, beefs.
But also any organized crime
that you've heard of, probably
in the last 8 to 10 years, so if
you think about the 2011 riots,
if you heard about
that big thing
that kicked off in Walthamstow
between two rival girl gangs
last week, organized gang-rapes,
organized robberies, organized
movements against the police,
or what they call the feds,
they absolutely will have had
some element of technology
driving it, and
probably quite a lot.
So it's definitely not
just a middle class
concern, the internet.
So on a slightly
more uplifting note,
will technology save the
future for young people?
Loads of scaremongery
articles, as I'm sure
you know from adults
about how technology,
in particular the
internet, is gonna
signal the end of civilization.
All newspapers will
become Buzzfeed.
All television shows
will be fronted
by AI versions of Davina
McCall and Stephen Fry.
And all shops will
be manned by robots.
Teenagers don't see
technology like that at all.
They don't see it as the
destruction of the future.
They see it as the
creation of their future.
And they're very,
very, very innovative,
and very creative
on the internet.
They vie, and they vlog,
they blog, they YouTube,
they create websites.
I do a Sunday show
with a lad who's 17.
He started an internet radio
show in his bedroom age 12.
Now age 17, he's sometimes
pushing seven figures
of listeners, and he's
courted by all these CEOs
and brands of the world.
And so that's just
a good example.
But I think what the
problem is there's
too much interface
with institutions
that children, that teenagers,
are caught up in that are too
wrapped up with the path.
And the best I can think of,
to finish this off today,
is education.
And when I was teaching I lost
count of the number of times
that I asked a kid to go
read something from the book,
or read a book, and they would
whinge and complain or not
do it.
And then as soon as you
gave them a screen, and said
go and read this on
a screen, whether it
was a laptop, or a
computer, whatever,
they go away and happily do it.
And they wouldn't
complain, and it would be
a completely different thing.
Hard, hard fact is
we have a big reading
problem in this country,
huge reading problem,
and it's gonna affect the
future of our country.
There's too many kids and
teenagers who are illiterate.
there are far too many who are
below the level of literacy
that they should be,
and I'd say probably 85%
if not more kids don't
read enough, particularly
when you compare them to
other countries and the kind
of reading levels
that they're doing.
And I think if we don't
do something about this,
we are heading for a
problem, because there's
no way to sugarcoat it.
Reading is essential for
academic and intellectual
development, both as an
individual and as a country.
I think the remedy
might be technology.
I think schools might be
too beholden to this idea
that reading has to happen
in an armchair in a corner
in a big tome of Dickens.
And they have to embrace that
this is how kids want to read.
I did a lot of work
for Wellington College
under Sir Anthony Seldon, who's
a real educational progressive.
Six years ago, he got rid of 75%
of the books in their library,
and replaced them with
screens and instructive forms
of reading, and they went
on to have unparalleled
academic success year-on-year.
Now, Wellington College is an
incredibly wealthy institution,
and state schools
don't have that kind
of equipment or money.
I'm a huge fan of the state
system, but it is buckling.
It is buckling under
a weight, and it's
heading for serious problems.
This is a government that
is tearing apart the state
education system piece
by piece, and it's
in desperate need of help.
Year-on-year, classroom
sizes increase.
So you'll have in one
classroom sometimes 35 kids.
And within that class
size, you can have kids
with an ability range from
serious learning difficulties
to genius.
So not every child
in there is gonna
have the learning
that they need.
Some kids really work
well with one-on-one.
Some kids work really
well in groups.
Some kids love rote learning.
Some kids love doing
project learning.
So all the kids in the state
system I spoke to pretty much
told me that the internet has
become their primary source
of top-up learning, because they
simply cannot facilitate this,
the kind of learning
that every child needs.
And I think this
needs to be embraced.
I think there needs to be a
collaboration between perhaps
companies like this and
all the many like them,
even though they're not
as good, in education,
because I think the state
system is in dire need of help.
So more online
learning resources.
We're not reading enough.
Kids don't have
access to books, so
what about a heavily
promoted teen marketed
online library service?
A talk like this probably will
primarily be watched by adults.
What about a teen channel,
where you have something like,
how to write the
perfect essay, what
the hell Hamlet's all about, the
night before a GCSE maths exam?
What about an online
live cramming session
with mathematician?
The night before an English
one, an online cramming session
with a writer?
So many, many possibilities.
No pressure here, and this is
the point I'm gonna finish on.
For teenagers in
particular, the internet
is so much more
than time and space.
It's where they learn,
where they're entertained,
where they're looking for
a guide to the future,
and maybe it needs to be
filled with more spaces
to innovate, and to
learn, and to inspire,
because companies
like this have become
some of the most
powerful in the world,
and all I would say is,
with great power comes
great responsibility.
And I wanted to leave
it with a final note
from Annabel, who's 15, who
said that if I woke up one
day and found the internet
and Google wasn't there,
I'd probably just
straight up die.
So Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So we have
20 minutes for questions
and one microphone here.
Chloe, please
repeat the question.
CHLOE COMBI: Yes.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: I know you
said that you'd rather
have a whole session
on YouTube, but it
would be really great
to also understand, just
highlight what you think teens
relationship is to YouTube.
CHLOE COMBI: To YouTube?
God, I mean, it would be better
to get a teenager in here.
It's unbelievably passionate.
I mean, YouTube as I'm sure
you know, YouTubers, they
have a particular slant,
like they do wacky songs,
or advice on life,
or makeup tutorials.
And that's what is it is,
and kids just eat this up.
They [INAUDIBLE] and follow
them in their millions.
And all I think
it is, and again,
it reiterates the
point I was making,
they see these people as like
the cool brother and sister
they never had.
And I think that's
just the relationship
they've developed with them.
But if you look at their
subscribers on YouTube
and the amount of followers
they have on Twitter and things
like that, it ranges
between like, from 500,000
to 20 million.
It's extraordinary.
And actually, you
probably will get them,
because the publishing industry
has really caught on to this,
and everything in the
Amazon top 100 at the moment
pretty much is
books by YouTubers.
So it's this real cash cow.
But I'm not a
teenager, and I have
talked to so many girls
and boys about this,
and inevitably girls are
[SHRIEKS] about these things,
perhaps more than boys are.
I think they are the
next One Direction.
I think they're the new boy
bands and boy [INAUDIBLE].
But also, I think it's because
it is a big thing for males
and females.
So I think it is very much
a sibling relationship,
and they have that
very intimate feeling
like they were in a gang or
a family if that makes sense.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have
a question in the back.
Sorry, we only have
one microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
so much for that.
I'm a mum with a
one-year-old, and frankly, I
find it terrifying.
CHLOE COMBI: Sorry!
AUDIENCE: Really
terrifying, but I
imagine you spoke to a broad
selection of Generation Zers,
and their relationships
with technology.
Were there any indicators of
differentiators between those
who had healthy relationships
with technology, where
it didn't impact
on their ability
to socially effective person.
Could you share that?
CHLOE COMBI: Healthy
relationships, I
think it's like anything.
I think I'm gonna sound really
old here, but I'm not a parent.
I don't have children
yet, but if and when I do,
I think what you really need
to make clear are perhaps
two or three things.
The number one, I
think that you need
to make absolutely clear
that the internet is not
the real world, that everything
on the internet to some extent
is airbrushed and commodified,
and sold and packaged
in a particular way.
And I think a lot
teenagers forget that,
and they buy into this
Instagram fantasy.
So that communication
to your kids
that the internet and whatever
they're looking at isn't real.
And also that insistence.
And I know the kids,
the teenagers who
I did speak to you
who I know and felt
like they had really
healthy relationships,
the ones that still
exist outside the screen
still go out with their friends,
go to the cinema, do stuff,
have this actually life
outside of technology.
And I think the ones
where I looked at them,
and I thought, this is a
little bit toxic, unhealthy
where they're just
completely living
in this internalized
screen world
and they spend all
their time online
and socialize
online, and just have
no separation between
technology and the real world.
And I think that's
possibly what we're heading
for more, and more, and more.
People don't meat
in bars anymore.
They meet on Tinder, and
that's a really good example.
But I think that's gonna
to be more and more extreme
as this generation goes on.
But just try and get them
reading, and socializing,
and talking, and interacting
in this time and space.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it's
a follow-up question, how
do you think we can do that?
How can we improve the situation
[INAUDIBLE] life 10 years on,
not just the social aspect,
but also the cyberbullying?
How do you think we can
make a possible impact
and change their lives?
CHLOE COMBI: So do
you mean their lives,
or the internet itself,
or a bit of both?
AUDIENCE: A bit of both.
CHLOE COMBI: It's
really hard, isn't it?
Because for lots of kids,
how does go to the Scouts,
or be a girl guide, or go
and be a champion swimmer,
or go and volunteer, or mow an
old lady's lawn?f and I think
that it can be quite hard
to sell reality when virtual
reality, to some kids, is
so much more appealing.
But I think, again, we have
to reiterate and reiterate
that there's no substitute
for actual human contact,
and human emotion, and that say
chatting to your mates online
is not the same, I think,
as sitting by them,
and having them
there, and so on.
To make things
better, all I can say
is I just think it's
information, information,
information.
And I think part of
the big problem is,
and I briefly touched
on that, I hope,
I think that there's
just not enough
clarity about the
laws and the rules,
and basically the
ethics of the internet.
Not like this is
what you have to do,
but this is what you
should want to do.
And I think, really, if
we've got any hope at all,
I think there needs to be
much more collaboration
between the internet
providers, and politicians,
and educators to
actually come up
with internet happy packages,
or something that sounds
a bit happy clappy, but
something that is a bit more
universally understood about
how you should behave online,
and probably maybe built into.
Go outside occasionally,
see the world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I wonder what you thought
[INAUDIBLE] as these guys grow
up, like when they're
in their 30s and 40s,
do you think that their actual
values will be [INAUDIBLE].
How worried should
we be about that?
CHLOE COMBI: The way we're
heading, bearing in mind
that I think that a lot
of this is easy to forget,
that a lot of this is
in its real infancy.
And in terms of
the internet, we're
all pretty much
in nappies still.
There's a real
newness to this world,
and I think we're making up
the rules as we go along,
and realizing there's
some things that need
to be improved or modified.
I think Twitter's a really
good example of this.
It started as this social
experiment that is just
going horribly, horribly wrong.
And I think it's turning
people into assholes.
And people are very quickly
saying this isn't good enough.
And I think if we ascribe those
values and that particular kind
of model to kids, I
think we are going
to learn how to manage the
internet better, and manage
our relationship with it better,
But it is a collaborative
If it continued on its
current trajectory,
I think we are in trouble.
I think we need to make some
really, really quick changes,
and very, very quickly.
So I think that's a
brilliant question.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You talked a lot
about schools, institutions,
and businesses.
The parents haven't
been [INAUDIBLE]
and I wonder is that
because parents just
don't have a clue what their
children are doing [INAUDIBLE].
CHLOE COMBI: Parents
and technology,
that's a brilliant question,
because I have written
a lot about this, about how kids
are basically running circles
around their parents
technologically.
And you get these really angry
emails going, how dare you!
I'm a wiz on owned technology,
and I know everything.
And I'm sure-- if any, how
many of you guys have kids?
I'm sure not many
of your kids would
be able to pull the wool over
your eyes, and say no, Dad.
It's a school project
on naked ladies!
But yes, yes, yes, yes.
I've got a four year-old
and a six year-old nephew,
and they do seem to have
this chip in their brain
that has this innate
understanding.
Before he could even
walk he was on the iPad.
And I just think
there seems to be
something they're evolved with.
But yes, I think
teenagers exist in a very,
very-- which is why Facebook
has become so diminished
in its popularity-- they exist
in this very private world
that they want to keep
separate from their parents.
They have this very, very,
very strong online identity
that, I think, is very,
very confidential to them.
And yes, I do.
I think for the most part,
if you read the book,
I mean, there's so may anecdotes
of parents them getting
into all kinds of
trouble There's
a girl who got groomed online, a
horrible few horrible examples.
And the parents have
absolutely no idea.
And I do think it's
like all of us.
We're all quite secretive
on the internet.
I mean, I don't
think any of us would
be that happy if your
mate was like let me look
at your history of browsing.
You'd be like, uh, must you?
And so if you think about
kids, they're really, really
secretive online.
So I think there is a problem
of this generational gap.
And I think it's
probably narrowing.
So kids who are in their late
teens and early 20s probably
have fairly clueless
parents, and then obviously
as the parents get younger,
that probably will narrow,
but right now, I
think is a big thing.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Some of what you talked about
sounds really depressing.
CHLOE COMBI: I know.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Did the teenagers
feel optimistic about life?
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHLOE COMBI: For these
talks, I sometimes do
go for the jugular.
And there are loads of
brilliant, and wonderful,
and amazing kids, and they're
doing brilliant, and amazing,
wonderful things.
And I promise you, it
isn't a bleak book.
But yes, the teenagers
are cautiously
optimistic about the future.
I think that they see that
there's many things in decline,
things like where 10 years ago,
there was a tangible dream,
I'm gonna go and
work for the Times,
or I'm gonna go and work
for The Daily Mirror
and become a journalist.
I think that's a
vanishing prospect,
and there's lots of career
vanishing prospects,
and they're very, very
well aware of this.
The other thing is,
I do think they've
become much more realistic.
Five years ago,
when I first started
writing about kids, when I
very first started teaching,
and they all were
like, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I'm gonna be famous.
What are you gonna famous for?
I'm just gonna be famous.
I'm either gonna be a famous
singer, or a famous footballer,
or what have you.
And I think they've
also realized
that that's a fairly
unrealistic dream,
and they need to have a plan B.
It's very much down
to the individual.
There's some kids who
just see the world,
and just see things that they're
gonna add to it, and create.
And there's some kids
who see the world,
and just see what
they wanna take.
And let's say fr
the most part, they
more fall into the
former category.
They're much more
optimistic, and giving,
and want to do
stuff for the world,
and contribute to the world.
But trouble is you
hear-- and I'm sometimes
a bit guilty of that-- the kids
who take too much stuff away.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
an interesting talk.
I totally get the point about
how they view technology.
I volunteer at this school in
north London, and some of them
ask me, how the hell can
you work for Google, sir?
Because it's just a website.
CHLOE COMBI: Right,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
question I want to ask
is, if a couple of the
issues are, as you mentioned,
this idea that [INAUDIBLE]
kind of curated online
and there's a lack of
core social contexts,
there's texting,
there's obviously
cyberbullying, et cetera,
it's far less inhibitive,
because you can't empathize
with a text message.
Do you think that the rise of
services like Snapchat which
are more unfiltered and
have the [INAUDIBLE] aspect
are a force for good when it
comes to cultural [INAUDIBLE].
CHLOE COMBI: It's a
really complicated one,
because I know completely
what you're saying,
that the in the moment can
give it more of that immediacy
that email completely lost,
and I think even texting does,
particularly as it's
backed up with pictures
and emoticons and
stuff like that
which underline your point.
I do know what you mean,
but at the same time,
I think that Snapchat is also
another barrier, because it's
like when you watch--
we're all guilty of this--
but when you watch kids doing
stuff, like, say having lunch,
they're all too
busy Snapchatting
their lunch to chat.
I know what you mean.
I think it's evolving the way we
do talk in that particular way,
and I think it is bringing
it into that real time,
and giving that kind of
immediacy and emotion.
But I think at the same
time it's another step back
from that human interaction.
And I don't whether
in 30 years time
whether we're just gonna
have screens for faces
with emoticons coming up.
AUDIENCE: Facebook's
working on it.
It's called Oculus.
CHLOE COMBI: There you go.
That's terrifying.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have time
for two more questions, one here
and one in the first
row [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I was looking up [INAUDIBLE]
changing nature of crime
and real decline in what
we might call [INAUDIBLE]
crimes or burglaries.
CHLOE COMBI: Absolutely, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And a massive rise in
terms of cyber crime and child
sex abuse.
If you were with the
Home Secretary right now,
what three things
would you ask him
to do that would make
a difference in terms
of that growth on child
sex abuse and cyber crime?
CHLOE COMBI: Well, this
is really interesting.
I actually just wrote an
article about this specifically,
this whole thing
about child sex crime.
And it's a big question,
and this is terrifying.
But one of the
things, when you go
into the serious
criminal world-- no,
not even the serious
criminal world, when
you go into the
streets of London,
you talk to kids involved
in criminal activity, one
of the things
that's fast emerging
is that drug dealing, and gun
running, and things like that
are high risk, but
pimping and the skin trade
is not high risk for the pimps.
It's high risk for the girls.
So kids, younger boys,
younger and younger men,
are getting more,
and more, and more
into pimping younger,
and younger, and younger.
And I think that
that is massively
being fueled and
encouraged by the internet,
and by this child
trafficking and things
like that on the internet.
So I think that because
you've got these police
units that are well in there
with the drug awareness stuff.
They're well in there
with the burglary stuff.
with the riot stuff.
They need to get sex
units on the streets,
and really, really quickly.
I was talking to 13
year-olds the other day,
and they all know girls who
were being pulled into the sex
industry, and girls who aren't
that much older, and so school
age girls.
And I know for a fact, I was
talking the grooming of girls,
particularly in what would be
considered high risk schools,
is very, very common.
I've written several about
this, 17 year-old boys,
they might look at a 30 or 40
year-old man, and think weird.
So what they're doing is
recruiting 17 year-old boys
to lure them in.
So it's become this hierarchy.
So that would be my
number one thing-- so
education and bringing
in these sex units.
And again, I wouldn't teach
my grandmother to suck eggs,
and come in here and
say I'm a cyber expert.
I'm not, but I'm
guessing they really
need to get more into
these cyber aspects of it.
Because it seems
to be like fungus.
It just pops up everywhere
on the internet,
and it's really awful.
Great question.
Though.
It's one to think about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: One more
in the front [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So teenagers are
quite famously [INAUDIBLE]
and these are quite
complicated issues,
and they might
not be predisposed
to listen to their parents,
the police, the government,
or teachers.
How do you think we
should try and communicate
to teenagers on these issues?
How are you gonna get
the message [INAUDIBLE]?
CHLOE COMBI: How are
you gonna communicate?
I think that's a
really good question,
and I think that I do know
the answer to this one,
even though it's maybe
not the complete one.
I think it's collaboration.
I think, again, this
book is in their voices.
It's them talking.
I didn't say to them this
is what I think you think.
I said to them, just
tell me what you think.
And teenagers are so used to
be being talked at and about
that no one ever sits
and says, well, tell me.
Tell me, well, how did you
feel when your mum died?
How did you feel when you
got kicked out of school?
How did you feel when
you got into Oxford?
And all these
stories are in there,
and I think that's the thing.
It's communication
and collaboration.
Rather than say, these
are the teen problems,
you say, you tell me
what teen problems are,
and let's sort this problem
out togetherness, and let's try
and come up with some answers.
And I think that that's
pertinent for what we're
doing on the
internet, how we deal
with quite a lot of
the internet problems,
and just generally how we're
going to improve as a species.
That's a profound note
to end on, wasn't it?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Please
join me in thanking
Chloe for coming on.
CHLOE COMBI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]